-Welcome back, everybody.
You know, here at "Late Night,"
every night,
I deliver a monologue
made up of jokes
written by a diverse team
of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk
that, due to my being
a straight white male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
We don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so we'd like to share them
with you now
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody!
These are two of our writers.
That's Amber.
That's Jenny.
-I'm Black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-Okay.
So I'm neither of those things,
so here's how it works.
I'll read the setups
to these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
The Pixar movie, "Lightyear,"
was recently banned
in the United Arab Emirates
because it contains
a lesbian kiss.
-Also containing a lesbian kiss,
most bachelorette parties.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-The African-American Museum
of Iowa
is planning
a $5 million renovation.
-That's how much it costs
to pick it up
and put it anywhere else.
[ Laughter ]
-A Mormon leader recently
called same-sex marriage
"the devil's work."
-Said lesbians, "I thought
the devil's work was makeup."
[ Laughter ]
-Is that true?
-No, the devil's work
is underwires.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know.
-They know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The co-creator of the sitcom
"Friends" donated $4 million
to the African-American Studies
department at her alma mater.
-But she needs to be donating it
to Regine, Max, Synclaire,
Overton, Kyle, and Khadijah.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Seth, do you know
who those people are?
-I do.
-How?
-Because every time "Friends"
come up,
you tell me it's a rip-off
of "Living Single."
-It is, and I demand justice!
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
In honor of gay people,
Burger King, this month,
released a special
Pride whopper.
-And in honor of lesbians,
they released chicken fingers.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
An investigation has found
that Black doctors are being
forced out of residencies at a
higher rate than white doctors.
-And that is not fair
because Black doctors
also deserve the opportunity
to tell me I'm making it up.
[ Laughter ]
-Tampax recently revealed
that demand for their tampons
has increased by nearly 8%.
-Which is great 'cause
they're usually in the red.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Oh, I wish I could've
told that one.
[ Laughter ]
The first Black woman
to visit every country
has written a book.
-It's called, "Uh-oh!
It's Like This Everywhere."
-Amber!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Sorry.
It's called
"Why Does Everyone
Keep Telling Me to Leave?"
-Amber!
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry.
It's called
"All the Places I Couldn't Find
Hair Care Products."
[ Laughter ]
-You know, Seth,
we love doing this segment...
-Mm-hmm.
-...but sometimes it feels
a little inefficient.
Like, I tell a gay joke...
-Then I tell a Black joke,
and back and forth,
blah, blah, blah.
-So, in an attempt to make
things more streamlined,
we found one person
who can do both.
-Oh, you did?
-Yeah.
Come on out!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, it's Wanda Sykes,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks for being here, Wanda.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Hi, Seth.
-Hi. You ready to do this?
-Fire away.
-All right, here we go.
The website Women's ERA
recently published a list
of interesting
conversation starters
for lesbians on first dates.
-Conversation starters like,
"When can you move in?"
[ Laughter ]
-A family in Canada was recently
followed by a black bear
during their hike
for nearly 20 minutes.
-Said the black bear, "Well,
now you know how I feel at CVS."
[ Laughter ]
-That was great.
That was a lot more efficient.
-Yeah.
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-Oh, guys, I just shouldn't.
-Come on, just one!
-I just don't feel like
it's gonna end well.
-Oh, come on, do it.
-Okay, I trust you guys.
Ethan Hawke is starring in
a new thriller called
"The Black Phone,"
and like all black phones,
expect it to ring
during the movie.
-[ Gasps ]
-Seth!
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, I --
I can fix it, don't worry.
Let me try again.
Ethan Hawke
is starring in a new thriller
called "The Black Phone."
"The Black Phone" --
pick it up if you want,
but it's gonna be
a bill collector.
-How dare you!
-You all told me
it would be okay!
-You should be ashamed
of yourself!
-Black women and lesbians
and Black women who are lesbians
are liars!
-[ Gasps ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We'll be right back
with Wanda Sykes, everybody.